mountain lion puma cougar all names for
an animal that has long been
misunderstood feared hunted and
eliminated from most of its range the
Cougar is often believed to be solitary
and even heartless but recently deep in
the Wyoming Wind River Range biologists
have placed motion cameras in dens and
in other secluded areas through the
camera's lens we're now able to peer
into the secret life of these animals
and see their close family ties and how
truly social interdependent and caring
they really are and what has emerged is
quite surprising even to the biologists
meet female 61 a new mother she's given
birth to three kittens the quiet male
m-72
another male m80 a firecracker to match
his name and f96
they're feisty sister kittens like these
depend on their mother until they're
nearly two years old
if 61 will devote most of her life to
nurturing and providing for her
offspring and that isn't easy in order
to feed them she sometimes has to leave
her three kittens alone for days at a
time when she finally returns from a
hunt she calls out and receives a warm
greeting from her kittens the kittens
are still young when the cameras
captured something astonishing f 61 an
m-80 are feeding together and suddenly a
large male emerges from the darkness
males like this one are known to chase
off kittens or even kill them but after
20 minutes the male settles in to share
the meal with F 61 and her kitten thanks
to the tracking collars we know that
this is actually a family reunion ma T
has just met his father for the first
time
soon the harsh winter makes it
especially difficult for this mother to
protect her kittens during a cold spell
temperatures plunged to 35 degrees below
zero
little f96 loses the tops of her ears
and tail earning her the nickname
frostbite unfortunately the family
suffers from more than brutal cold and
midwinter a pack of hungry wolves
arrives and attacks the Cougar family
m-72 the shy male does not survive as
the months pass f60 one continues to
care for her two remaining kittens
watching for danger and correcting their
playful behavior when they get a little
too rough as the kittens grow we're able
to see intimate glimpses into their
clothes social bonds we see long lazy
spells of napping grooming wrestling
playing tag and for ma T a refresher on
table manners the camera catches another
rare and unexpected moment when
frostbite appears to be coughing and we
are able to see her mother come in to
comfort her
when m80 reaches 18 months old believes
his mother and sister behind in search
of a new home and eventually a mate this
is really a time for hope a chance for
all of f60 one's maternal care to pay
off but after eight months 150 miles
from his birthplace his search comes to
a tragic end he is killed by a trophy
hunter the deaths of m-72 in m80 remind
us that it's not easy being a cougar
habitat loss trophy hunters harsh
winters and wolves in the Wind River
Range fewer than one in five kittens
survived to raise a family fewer than
one in five the good news is F 61 the
Wind River mother is a survivor she's
captured on camera once again raising a
new litter of kittens she is even
adopted an orphaned kitten one of
several adoptions that wildlife
biologists have uncovered with this new
research a little frostbite she too has
beaten the odds and should soon be
raising her own kittens will her kittens
survive to have families of their own
perhaps the cameras will tell us it's
hard to imagine what these and other
Cougars go through in the wild but what
we can understand is family and the
moments captured here have shown us the
true nature and personalities of these
American icons their power their beauty
and how affectionate and caring they
really are
and with help from us we can guarantee
their safe and rightful place and ensure
that these remarkable animals are around
long into the future
[Music]
you